(upbeat music)
- Governments today are grappling
with the change brought
about by technology.
The shift and demands
of citizens expectations
and service standards
has created a new need
for governments worldwide
to seek new definitions
of design and delivery.
GX Now tracks key
governments across the world,
in the hope of finding
answers to what governments
of tomorrow will look like.
How they will deliver
excellence and why experiences
maybe the key to unlocking
the value behind government
citizen engagements.
GX is an idea born out of
the United Arab Emirates,
created to fulfill the promise
of government service
delivery and changing it to
an experience.
The model is now slowly
evolving to become a template
that can be used globally to create
government service delivery excellence.
In GX Now, you will hear a
collection of global perspectives
coming from both the public, as well as
from the private sector.
The opinions of guests in this documentary
or to a huge extent based
on their experiences
of working with governments
and being at pivotal positions
where governments and the
private sector interface.
Looking at some of the
biggest opportunities ahead,
and also some of the challenges
governments must face
in the next few years.
GX Now is the story of
dreaming big of excellence,
of changing perceptions and
of creating a better future
for government services worldwide.
My name is Ian Khan.
Thank you for joining me on this journey.
If you look at the current
state of the government
experience domain, there
really isn't a standard.
Everybody across the world
is doing things differently,
and there's an impact
of different industries
on government experience.
And some parts of the world
government experience dictated
by the retail sector,
and we make a comparison
between retail services
and government services.
What is happening within
government is also an aftereffect
of how other industries
are serving their clients
their clientele, and their client base.
Governments across the world are trying
to adapt to different things.
And in times of political
instability, changing governments,
the priorities of
governments are changing.
Let's talk to Jonathan Reichental.
I spoke to Jonathan about his experiences
and the that he's seen
governments have across the world.
Now Jonathan works with
governments from Asia
to the middle East, to the
Americas and in Europe as well.
And he knows the pulse of governments
and the challenges that
governments are facing.
Jonathan is a big advocate
of change as a professor,
as an educator and as a business owner,
his thoughts are critical
in helping us understand
where we should go and
what governments should do
in order to progress.
- One of the things I'm
observing as I have the privilege
to visit many different
governments and cities around
the world, it's number one a recognition
that communities have
much higher expectations
of service delivery today.
And so if you're a community member,
you're used to using consumer
apps on your smartphone
or going to a website, and then
you use a government service
and it's not nearly as good or perhaps
it's not even digital.
The senses now that this is becoming
no longer acceptable, we
have to step the game up.
- One of the participants of
the GX program is Jane Wiseman.
I spoke to Jane about what are
the challenges of government
and what do governments
and the veteran world face,
especially in the United States
and what are her experiences
of government service and
government service excellence.
- Half of Americans can't
tell the difference,
between a Google search
result and a Google ad.
We need better data literacy
so that we can be savvy
about what are reliable sources of fact.
- Tim Unwin is the UNESCO chair in ICT
and he's also professor at
the Royal Holloway University
in London.
Tim brings a lot of experience
when it comes to working
internationally at a grassroots level.
And what's the state of
government experience and services
in Europe.
- In many countries of the
world, people don't trust
their governments.
And I'm speaking from
my experience in Africa.
They often are willing to
trust the private sector rather
than governments.
So I think there's some
really interesting things
around that, but if people
don't trust governments,
they're not gonna be willing to engage
with those service provision.
Unless of course the
government makes it essential
that they do so through
their digital systems.
I remember a few years
ago, many countries saying
we're going to go digital by
default, but that automatically
excludes those who aren't digital.
People with disabilities,
elderly people they are going to
be marginalized by any
move to government services
unless alternative
mechanisms are put in place.
So actually you're going to
need to provide service centers
where people can come to.
So digital by default will marginalize.
- Marloes Pomp was the head of blockchain
and the head of AI
partnerships for the government
of Netherlands is an amazing resource.
She has so much knowledge and
information because she works
with other governments
from across the world.
As head of blockchain and
some very critical programs
by the government of Netherlands.
Marloes knows what
challenges of governments
are when it comes to
technology implementation
- In the Netherlands, the
government has selected
five key technologies like blockchain,
artificial intelligence, big
data, cybersecurity, and 5g.
And we will invest in this technology more
in the coming years to
improve the services.
We try to build a human
centric applications,
it also means that we have
a lot of folks on the risk
of these new technologies,
for example the government
already uses a lot of AI in their services
but of course there's also
the risk of discrimination.
So that's why the Ministry of Justice
has launched a guideline for
all the governmental services
are using new technologies
like artificial intelligence.
- I also spoke with the
head of the e-Residency
for the Estonian government.
Ott Vatter has been working
for the government Estonia
for many years, and he
brings a lot of experience
when it comes to working with startups,
working with international
bodies, international governments
and he shared some
really critical insights
when it comes to government experience.
And what does the
e-Residency program hold,
and why is it such a great
example of creating government
experience that is seamless
and it adds a tremendous amount
of value for any country of any size.
- The difference between
government services in EU,
in Asia in US is very large
and the EU has some similarities
here, but again looking
at conservative countries who
do not have maybe that amount
of trust for the government
or government keeping
their data safe which
is also very important,
then these services cannot develop.
Looking at countries like
India, was rolling out
an identity program as well
but 1.3 billion compared
to our Estonia is 1.3 million
is a bit of another challenge.
- Estonia is one of the
biggest examples that is used
when it's about government
using technology
and creating efficiency
in what governments do.
I spoke with the CIO of
the Government of Estonia
Siim Sikkut.
We talk about what his
challenges have been
and how he sees the
government experience changing
from an Estonian perspective.
- Our main approach is to
make services invisible
as much as we can.
Let's not focus on
interactions, let's focusing on,
delivering a value rather.
So value is for example,
we ensure compliance,
that's why we ask the entrepreneur
for some sort of report
even if we ask it online.
And my point here is being
that if we think of it from
that perspective, we often see
that we don't need to design
for those individual
interactions as services.
We can get rid of many
online services literally
by automating things away.
And so if we need the philosophy side,
what it practically means
is we're trying to install
at least kill different
online services we've built up
by adding more automation,
adding more sort of data
integration a bit more small data
analytics and stuff like that.
One of the first approaches on that
parents of newborn babies
don't have to apply
for parenthood benefit, it's automatically
being sort of crowded for them.
We are building it up for companies that,
if companies will consent and agree,
the government have access
to the financial records,
the same data that is digital anyways,
then we won't ever bother
them with a report,
not for tax, not for
employment, not for statistics
not for annual reports so forth.
All these things the
companies can now do online,
why do we bother them with an extra step?
If you have the data it's done
- There are definitely
outliers and there's definitely
countries that are making a solid effort
in the right direction.
To fully understand the commitment that
the Government of the United Arab Emirates
has provided to the government
experience initiative
and to set forth a precedent
in government service delivery.
I spoke with someone who's
leading these efforts
at the prime minister's office
in the UAE Mohamed Bin Taliah.
- In the past, the focus
was more on how we build
the services in terms of processes,
in terms of transforming
services from being manual
to becoming automatic and paperless.
However, the customers today
look for services that are more
towards their experience
and other parts of services
in the world that they are familiar with.
And they would like to
see government services
being delivered in a
similar way or even better.
- Alain Bejjani is the CEO
of the Majid Al Futtaim Group
in the UAE.
The Majid Al Futtaim Group
is one of the largest groups
managing retail in the Middle East.
Alain shared a lot of critical insights,
how the retail sector affects government,
how governments can learn
from the retail sector.
Alain also works for
the World Economic Forum
and different governments and
bodies can creating thought
leadership ideas and initiatives
that affect governments worldwide.
- The fourth industrial
revolution is a reality
within it.
And I would say it's very important
that the rate of change on
the inside be at least equal
if not faster than the rate
of change on the outside.
It's also allowing us to be
able to deal with some of the
endemic issues that we
couldn't deal with before,
technology today presents
that capability to do that
and is becoming more ubiquitous,
more affordable and more simple to use.
It's now on us, our generation
of leaders to make sure
that we turn this into the
opportunity that it actually is,
and to make sure that we can drive
sustainable economic
growth, employment creation,
job creation and we can
drive a better integration
of our societies in the world.
- Fadi Hindi is the CEO of
an AI based company focused
within the insurance industry,
but he brings a lot of
critical insight to the idea of GX.
- Over the past, maybe
five to eight years,
customers are no longer
willing to tolerate delays
or lack of transparency or not
knowing what's the next step
or being mistreated for that matter.
Historically, the economy
was more like product driven
in the seventies, and then
you get into the eighties
and the nineties, and now it's more moving
towards like a relationship economy.
- We live in the experience economy,
and I think this is something
that you would see more
and more and more.
When you think about the effort
that we're putting together
across the board, private
sector, public sector
and how we all try to put
everything that on the customer
make sure that the customer
is actually the epicenter.
And how can we actually,
from a government standpoint
contribute to that quality of life,
contribute to that will be,
take away all the uncertainties
that come with it and give
them the ability to focus on
what they would like to focus on,
what they love most and
what they like best,
which is a service that's
one curated around them,
two, that it's there when they need it.
And actually think about what does
the customer slash citizen need
and not what does the government need.
For very long time
governments have been focused
on actually designing
services or that implementing
those designs in a way
that suits the governments
from different perspectives.
And I think what you're
seeing here is actually
a total diverse.
- I spoke with government in
Azerbaijan and the head of the
ASAN service center.
The ASAN service centers
have completely changed
the idea of service delivery
by bringing together
different vendors and as
many as 300 plus services
at the one place.
It has radically changed
how government is delivering
services at a service center level.
- Traditionally ways
are not suitable anymore
to provide our services and
to get satisfaction level.
But also we know that it's
not only about technologies.
It's also about organizational structures.
It's about human resources
and we are trying
to build suitable environment
in order to provide
our services effectively and
efficiently to our citizens.
- Where the government has
placed an incredible emphasis
on this, is the recognition
that everyone is different.
And a tremendous experience
is often not something
that is entirely frictionless,
like booking a train ticket,
it's not that difficult to
say what does the station
you need to go to, what time,
where are you leaving from
and how many passengers are there.
That's a very automated process that
has almost no variations.
But when you're trying to change your name
and actually the options that you're going
for a not available or when
you're trying to consume
healthcare services and
you have two children
who are naturally born, one is adopted.
These are the types of unique
situations that actually,
when organizations are able
to deal with that effectively
that's what makes people
feel really good about it.
Because it makes it feel
like they actually understand
that there are very
personalized requirements
that citizens have.
- If you sit at home, how is
your feeling about the services
you get from the government?
Are you worried about
missing out or forgetting
about paying your bills,
your utilities bills,
or are you comfortable
because you know that it will
automatically be processed
through your digital assistant,
that kind of level, and
that kind of experience
is what we're seeking, where
a customer does not need
to worry everything runs in the background
on their behalf.
- Consuming government
services anywhere in the world
is normally met with the
thought of bureaucracy
and lots of paperwork.
I think what's different here
is that there has been an
incredible focus on
making sure that the pain
and the friction that normally is involved
with the yearly renewal of
services has been taken away.
Now whether that is having your
car renewed which is almost
entirely a digital transactional,
whether that is year national ID
or whether that's just
paying for your parking
through your mobile phone.
Everything is interlinked.
And what's very neat is
there is a single portal app
where you can then go on
and whether it's hospitals
or funeral parlors or
government service centers,
all of that information is
not housed in one place.
- I survey that three
quarters of CEOs think
that customer experience is very important
to their business.
But there's no such survey in government,
I don't know how many
government leaders think
the customer experience is top priority,
but I'll tell you there are 10
million government employees
and it's not top priority for everyone.
- So let's say you have to go to a place,
you have to go to a physical place.
What's the experience
like when you get there?
Is it crowded and chaotic?
Do you know what to do?
Do you get good customer service?
Do you talk to people
that are well-informed
and if they have difficulty
themselves getting you
the information, do they have
access to information tools
to help you as a community member.
I think I see governments
now beginning to think about
the entire life cycle of a process.
For example, getting a copy
of your birth certificate.
When you want to submit
a request for a permit
which just such a common
city or government activity,
it shouldn't be as hard as it is today.
People don't look forward to
that and the experience should
be better.
You should be able to
and increasingly request
a permit online without
having to go to a place
and take a number and
wait spend half your day
in the government office.
- In the United Arab
Emirates we focus on customer
experience from their life instances.
So for example, if the
customer has a newborn baby
we look at that as an
a point of life where
they need government services
about having a new baby.
Therefore, we started looking
at it from a bundling perspective.
So instead of a customer
looking at which government
entities or government service
centers they should visit,
they just know what bundle they want.
I'll give you an example
of one of the services
that we have, it's called Mabrouk Ma Yak,
which means congratulations
on your newborn.
And it's bundled more than
seven services into one step
and more than five
payments into one payment.
And to get everything
related to this newborn
within three hours now using this bundle.
- We are now moving from
a milestone shopping model
to non-stop shop model.
In our service centers, we are
providing reactive services
to our citizens, but now we
started launched new project
which is called my growth,
my government project.
And it's about providing proactive
services to our citizens.
For that we are ready widely
using beta in order to predict
expectations of our citizens.
And in-house by the government,
we are trying to involve
the companies to this process as well.
- As the result of really
rapidly changing world,
what is changing is also
citizen expectations.
Citizens today expect a
different level of service
at a government level.
The expectations are a
combination of what they're seeing
in the private sector,
in the retail sector
in the healthcare sector in a
combination of this is leading
to the overall citizen need if you will,
for service excellence.
Today's citizens, you and
I, we all use smartphones
and technology to make
decisions, to access services.
And it's very common just
to expect that every service
should be available on a cell
phone, it should be available
on a mobile device, but not
all governments have been able
to translate services from
a service center to online.
- Most, so-called governance
agendas are actually about
governments providing services
to people through technology.
So we can see government
websites where you can access,
forms to fill in passports
or licenses or pay tax.
That is a really interesting
change of management structure.
In the old days, governments
had lots of civil servants,
lots of people working for
them to do the paperwork.
Now the effort and load has
been transferred back down
to the citizens.
It's like in the old days, when
you might attend a meeting,
somebody would send you all
the paperwork in advance.
You didn't have to do anything,
you just read the paperwork
and took it to the meeting.
Now your sent the files digitally by email
or another online system,
or even you're expected to go online
to download those forms
yourself, then read them,
then perhaps print them
off because you might need
to take them to the meeting.
So that is a shift of labor
from governments to citizens
or from organizations to employees.
I hate, having to log on to
three or four different sites
every day to get information,
whereas it could easily
just be sent to me in another form.
The standard rhetoric is of
course, that it makes it much
easier for governments
and citizens to interact
on key things that they need to do.
And that undoubtedly have its
advantages, it's very easy now
to submit a passport application online
or your tax forms online.
Second point though, is
and I'll use the example
of our own government digital service.
There are many great things about gov.uk.
However, if you want to find out anything
from the government website
about a government department
or what it does, it's almost impossible.
And I think that is an
indication there's difference
between government service
provision and the relationship
between governments and
citizens and the openness
and the transparency around that.
- Today I think citizens are co-creators
in a government experience.
There's an opportunity for
each of us to be partners
and help get stuff done,
a greater openness in,
more progressive cities and
more tools for collaboration
are allowing community members
in particular to participate
in everything from
decision-making to design sessions
even development of solutions.
There's some very interesting
experiments been done
with community, co-funding,
identifying funds
from public sector and private
sector to get projects done
that has been difficult to get moving
because of the reliance
purely on public funds.
If a government makes available data
and the community member says,
hey I could build a solution
using that data.
Wow, that's a great relationship,
that's a great partnership.
We have software engineers
now who can step up
create interesting solutions
or try to make sense of data
and serve up the analytics
that helps decision
makers make better decisions.
That's a relationship
we've never had the tools
to be able to do before.
A good democratic government experience
is not a spectator sport, it's
something you participate in.
- State of Washington is one
of my favorite performance
driven organizations.
There's something called
results Washington.
Every single metric about state government
is available online, drill
downs to get greater detail.
And when the governor
hosts a results meeting,
the public is invited.
It's streamed live online, but
they also include a customer
or two or three in every single meeting.
So if it's about youth
development, there are actually
youth they're giving
feedback to the government
about how the services
are improving, where they
need more improvement.
So that's a great example
at the state level.
And right now, 90% of our
federal government websites
are collecting customer feedback
and trying to iteratively improve.
- My takeaway is that,
it's really interesting
what's happening in the world today.
The amount of data that is
generated on a daily basis
is just mind-boggling.
Yet you talk to a lot of the enterprises,
you talk to government, you
talk to a private sector,
you talk to large corporates
and they will tell you
that they have poor data,
issues with quality, there
are gaps in the data.
There's a problem.
- There's a lot of legacy
systems and data that's out there
that's quite difficult to
mine and bring to the surface.
When you're building something greenfield
is much more simple to
do that from A to Z.
But the truth is a lot
of government departments
have huge legacy of information
systems that they're using
untraditional processes.
So the difficulty is trying
to stitch those together
in a format that the customer
doesn't feel any bumps.
It's like having a shopping
trolley being pushed across
a railway track, very bumpy experience.
And what you're trying to do is take all
of those knots out of the experience.
- In all sources you
need a form of identity,
but it's identity it sounds
like there's only one identity.
And I expect you have several
identities which you can use.
So I will use another identity to log in,
in my for example, my Google accounts
then I will use for governmental
services for examples.
I hope these digital
identities, several identities
are owned by me and are controlled by me.
- The state of Indiana recently
created a single sign on,
so that I can get my park
permit and my driver's license,
certifications, any government
activity that I'm doing
with the state is all under one ID.
So that I don't have to
continually reenter my information
so that's wonderful sort of one-stop shop.
But, we're still a long way
from being able to integrate
from the federal to
the state, to the local
with a single identity.
And I think it's probably
worth being careful about this,
because with a single identity
in government comes risk,
could it be hacked, when it's
done by the private sector
government doesn't have the control,
and can't police it in the
way that might be necessary.
So for example in the us, we
have for the ability to travel,
the Transportation Security
Administration is responsible
for issuing TSA pre-check,
so that they vet me
and then I can go in an express lane.
Well, there's also a private sector entity
that's doing that.
What is the fundamental
role of government?
Should it be the government
that says who can get
on a plane and is safe
to travel and who isn't.
- If you let the government
have all of your identity,
what might they do with it?
I often liken this to what
happened in Rwanda, where the use
of older digital technologies,
radio for example,
enabled many parts of the genocide there
to happen more efficiently.
So if a government knows
everybody's identity
and where they live and
everything about them
what can they do with that information.
For migrants, it's very often issues
around weather qualifications for example,
gained in one country can be compatible
with those games in another country.
Imagine if everybody
had a digital identity,
that they could take with
them, so that if you are moving
from Kenya to South Africa
or from Haiti to Brazil,
actually you can take
your identity with you.
I think that raises really
exciting possibilities
not only for migrants,
but also for governments.
If we could get global
agreements around what their
parameters and what the credentials
in digital identity meant, that
could be really beneficial.
- So it won't be one
technology which will solve
the identity topic.
It will be a combination,
and this moment we really try
to figure out how can we
combine a digital identity
with privacy preserving technologies
like zero knowledge proofs
or multi-party computation.
I think this is a really
interesting area to explore
at an international level.
- We believe in Estonia
that digital identity
is the backbone of everything.
Every person should have
an identity match to them
physically and digitally.
So, every Estonian communicates
with the government
using their digital identity
meaning they do everything
from bank statements, taxes
to registering the childbirth,
using the digital identity.
And we really can't imagine
our life any other way.
- It's been nice actually for
us as Estonian government,
the learning journey to get
to have experience in focus.
I'll be very honest here, I
think we've been very techie
and engineer led throughout
our sort of beginning years
especially, in a sense that
seeing okay, how much better
how much more efficient we
can be if we functionally
build things up and for
example put services online,
whatever the experience.
Now we really come to
the point that took it
to the next level, obviously
experience has to be
at the forefront, because
otherwise we don't have people
as using it.
And, so it goes off course way
beyond just issues of nice,
neat design of an online environment.
Our core focuses is how do we
make the process, the working
of government into the best experience.
And in often case for
us just to look forward,
I mean, it's about how
do we simplify radically
because the best
experience, at least as far
as the student is
concerned, if there's none,
if that happens for me.
As an Estonian, it's
very hard to give advice
and physical service centers,
because for us digital
journey has meant getting
rid of them largely.
- There is the tax board
that has a physical standard
and perhaps the post.
But otherwise, if we talk
about governmental services
they are 99% online.
- If you can't get access
to digital in whatever means
because you don't have connectivity,
you don't have electricity.
You're gonna be further
marginalized by the delivery
of digital services.
The classic example is around
the notion of smart cities.
I often say just by saying
the word smart cities,
actually implies villages are fairly dumb.
So one of the main challenges is very much
that you can't deliver say
what you can in a small
densely populated area
that has full connectivity.
That's why it's so
important to have access
in the first instance.
- And not all our citizens
are technologically literate.
That's why we need us on service centers
in all parts of our country.
Also, we have mobile buses.
This buses are specially equipped
with different technologies.
We sent that buses to the remote areas
where we don't have ASAS
service centers in order
to serve our citizens.
And also we have volunteers.
- The human factor within
the government experience
is a primary factor.
From all perspectives, I would say.
So if it is a, from a customer perspective
or from a government employee perspective,
even the employees who work
on delivering government services,
we looked at their happiness level.
We looked at how they
understand what customers want.
Therefore, we have conducted
a series of trainings.
It's a customer happiness
training, where we look
at the frontline employees
who provide the services.
We trained them on how to
conduct business in a manner
that will make the
customer happier and also
at the same time, we looked
at the supervisors of these
government service centers which we call
the United Arab Emirates, the
customer happiness center.
And we trained them on how to supervise
a team of customer happiness officers.
- I'm not in favor of
absolutely 100% abolishing
every government service
physically, because we see
that some regions for Estonia,
this is the kind of only
form of communication
that some of these people
actually have and they enjoy
these forms of communication.
They enjoy going to the post office,
but in terms of city life, in
terms of actually going to the
tax office and waiting
three hours to fill in
the stack of paper, that
should be eliminated absolute.
- The way the shape government
services is really clear.
We need across the board,
a template of excellence.
We need something that
can be easily adapted,
easily deployed.
For example, if a country
has a model of excellence
is that model able to be
replicated across different groups,
across different
departments and ministries.
That's exactly what is needed.
The GX program in the United Arab Emirates
is an excellent example of that.
Government service
excellence is a top priority
for the government of the UAE.
Things such as tweeting
about the rankings of
government service centers is
not very uncommon in the UAE,
and this is how leadership
runs the country.
- GX was created with the
vision and mind to drive
the attention of people
working on services,
regardless to the type of
customers or the persona
of the customer, we need
to focus on that experience
of that customer.
Now who is part of the GX, everyone.
So it could be private
sector, could be investors,
startups, entrepreneurs.
Who could be part of the GX platform,
has multiple aspects to it,
we have the government services
forum that brings leaders
from around the world,
around the table to discuss
government services.
We have the GX online platform
that shares knowledge base,
how governments around the world
improve customer experience.
We have also the GX talks.
So the GX talks also focused
on getting thought leaders
from different backgrounds
to talk about experience
of customers, whether
it is digital experience
or it is also the physical experience
or even experience that
has no touch point.
So for example, if you sit at home,
how is your feeling about the
you get from the government?
Are you worried about
missing out or forgetting
about paying your bills,
your utilities bills
or are you comfortable because you know
that it will automatically be processed.
- The UAE is an impressive nation.
They've got the advantage
of being fast and nimble
and agile right now in the way
that they go after initiatives.
Plus they've got leadership
that's truly vested and believes
in going digital and adopting
the fourth industrial revolution.
I think these ingredients,
when you put them together
gives you a very unique
environment because of the platform
that's been created by investing
in this futuristic thinking.
- It's not just their
vision and their talk,
but they're building
things and doing things.
I've been able to experience
these things firsthand
in Dubai
For example, their concept
around the future police station.
It's a beautiful experience.
People feel safe.
And a lot of it is done by
use of digital technologies,
assistance from the right
resources via video conference,
which I thought was incredible.
You see a lot of
experimentation and prototyping,
you see very bold projects,
everything from smart Dubai
right through to the paperless
society, thus making the cost
of government be less,
data to be more accurate
all the benefits we would expect.
One of the big ones the
environmental positive side of not
having oldest paper.
They're doing the things,
they're demonstrating,
they're experimenting, they're
helping other communities
and cities and governments
around the world
see what's possible.
Sharing these insights with the world,
I'm wanting you to create
things like the GX forum,
which becomes a global platform to say,
hey what there's different ways
to have a government experience.
We've got to be able to
create channels that takes
these best practices,
the stuff that goes well
and maybe even the learnings of the stuff
that doesn't go so well all the time
and share it with governments
in every corner of the world.
- So I think the thing that's
important about it being
an international conversation
and frankly being
in-person conversation,
because we're all busy.
If we just try to get
together by phone or webinar,
we're gonna get distracted though.
But when you plant yourself
physically with other people
you make the kinds of
connections that last
and that allow us to
keep advancing the ball
to continue to refine our thinking
and to challenge each
other that sense of almost
like a healthy peer competition,
like, oh I'm gonna have
to have something to say
when I get back together
with this group, what have I done?
What do I bring to the table?
So I think that's a real value
that we can see in this group.
- It's really necessary
to have experiments
within your own organization,
but otherwise it's still
complicated to have these
discussions with other partners
who develop services.
So you must test and explore a little bit
within your own organization.
You must train your employees,
there are hardly any projects,
very don't have to collaborate.
So it's really important
to learn how you can build
from coalitions and I've
kind of agreements we need,
the legal issues around
these collaborations,
the governance models.
- Of course, it is very
difficult to implement our ideas
as it is.
Because every country has own
cultures, as on tradition,
as on environment.
And you can see how they are
challenged in that environment
and how they solve that problems
during the implementation process.
- Initiatives like this can often tend
to be wanting to come up with
the best global solution.
But these ideas are
evolving, the relationship
with citizens states is evolving.
Technology is evolving.
So a little bit more
I think self-critique,
and not always positive
about some of the activities
that happen, because
technology can use for good
and it can be used for bad.
And it's how immediate those
in the interests of citizens.
For me citizens are
actually more important
than governments.
Governments should serve their citizens.
- We have learned for
me residency experiences
to try to put yourself
in the shoes of the user.
Because we see quite often that that's
what government officials are lacking.
So they sit in their silos and
they don't talk to the users,
they don't understand the
needs of the users in the age
of smartphones and all of
the private sector services
that we actually consume all the time.
We can't expect our
governments to lag behind.
We believe in Estonia that
governments can never compete
with private companies, and they should,
but governments are the ones
who have to offer government services.
So it's time to actually go together
with the trends what's
happening in the world.
The global star rating program,
is the first of its kind
that assesses government service centers
as if they are cartels.
So just like when you walk into a hotel
and you see that this
hotel is a five-star hotel
and you understand what
experience you're gonna be getting
from a five-star hotel,
the same similar concept has been applied
to government service centers.
Hassan Chef Hamad, guided us
to make United Arab Emirates
government as efficient
as banks and works 24/7
like airports.
Since this program has been
launched, we have realized
the fruits of this program by seeing
customer happiness center
has improved significantly
over the past eight years.
- The Edelman Trust Barometer
ranks the UAE very high
the highest it's not the
second highest in the region
and one of the highest in the world,
I think with the focus centers.
The UAE has always designed
its government services
and looked at government
services as actually an enabler
to society.
Today the UAE is looking forward and say,
I want to do even more than even better.
I want to be even more customer centric.
I want to make sure that
my government services
are actually not just
the best in the world,
but the most satisfactory
in the world for the people
that choose them.
And actually, how can
I enhance their life?
How can I actually add
value to their lives?
And this is something that
we're seeing happening day in
day out.
This culture of transparency
that's coming across more
and more in the UAE.
In order to be the best in the world,
we have also to hold up the mirror.
And this is something that
you're seeing happening
and that think the government
is leading by example.
- The future of the GX program
by the prime minister's office
in the United Arab Emirates
is strong.
It's something that's tangible.
It's something that can
be developed and adopted
by every government service
program in the world.
But it needs work, it needs
work, because implementation
of these things is complex.
You need stakeholders to
agree on these things.
You need to get the buy-in from
people who run governments.
And those are some of the
challenges that other governments
might face when adopting this program.
We live in an era of disruption,
fast changing expectations
in order to make the world a better place,
we will have to play the
game in a different way
whether it's GX or any other program
at a government service level,
it needs the commitment of the leadership
of these countries, of these
departments and groups.
- So this is an amazing time.
There is so much potential
and we need two things.
We need, number one, to
listen and number two to act.
And when you put those two things together
it makes a huge difference.
So in the US the veterans administration
which serves former
members of the military
who are now back in the country,
they started a customer
satisfaction survey,
and it turns out people
who responded to the survey
and gave feedback were
four times more satisfied
with government than others.
Now don't know yet whether
some of that is a sample bias,
that those who decided
to answer the survey
were more satisfied.
But to me, it also says that
there is power in just asking
for feedback.
When you engage the public,
they become more excited.
The city of Santa Monica,
California has a wellbeing index.
They have decided that
the purpose of that city
is to support the wellbeing of its people.
One of the things they've done
is social media sentiment mining.
So they can tell which
neighborhoods are showing
through the publicly available information
on Facebook and Twitter.
What neighborhoods are under stress,
what neighborhoods are worried about money
and how can the city really
do something about that.
We now have drug treatment in jails
because the people who were coming out
of jails were 120 times more likely
than the average person
to die of drug overdose.
So now we can do
interventions in our jails,
because the data approach
allowed us to target.
When community members got to participate
and help the government
choose where the money goes.
When the people made the decisions
there was more investment in health,
more investment in education.
And some of those early
cities that employed this,
showed lower incidents of infant mortality
five years, 10 years from
now, I think we're gonna have
a much higher level of trust
in government, because with all
of these new ways of engaging the public,
there are untapped ideas and resources
and potential for really making
government just far better
than it's ever been.
- We are planning to implement
personalized services
for our citizens, from any
country, from any place,
from the result and barriers.
And to be accessible and
available for that we need also
to implement a new technologies,
AI machine learning,
deep learning and other technologies.
Now we are implemented
shared cloud-based document
floor system and it helps
us to reduce the costs
for building that services and
to optimize that processes.
- The governments of the future
are going to be focused more
on purpose and less on services.
Services are gonna be done.
Artificial intelligence
machine learning is gonna
take care of most of the
services being delivered.
We're gonna be focusing more
on thinking about our future
on how we can magnify life
as a nation, as a community
the governments will have
much more time capabilities
and much higher caution when
it gets to the livability,
when it gets to the future of
government is gonna be about.
A lot of the problems that we know today,
a lot of the topics that
you are trying to solve
for today are not gonna
be there in 10 years time.
We are all gonna be
augmented in our capabilities
as human beings.
We're gonna be able to do more for less,
but also we're gonna be able
to actually focus on where
we actually make the
biggest difference and drive
the biggest impact, not in
terms of the small things
that happen around us, in terms
of enriching life on earth
and how we can actually be
a continuous agent of change
and progress.
- I believe that AI is definitely
going to be the next cycle
of major revolution in
technology and what we're gonna
be able to do with it
are a lot of products
and services that were
not possible in the past.
But it's not my belief that
the AI algorithm is gonna
become sentient one day and
wake up, then figure out
that humans need to be eradicated.
Let's be more pragmatic and
more realistic, and let's not
worry about the scifi part.
The part of AI that's really
exciting are most helpful
for corporate user or
the corporate worker.
The first one is this
concept of digital twin.
And the concept of the digital twin,
is that it's an assistant
working side-by-side
with the human to be able
to improve the quality
of the type of work that
they're doing by relegating
all the mundane manual
tasks over to the AI
and the automation.
So that the human is actually focusing
on the things that they
should be focusing on,
not filing the papers, not
thumping through things
and trying to index, 1000
pages that should all be done
by machines.
And the digital twin
should be providing this
workflow automation for the
human to become more effective
and more efficient.
- A lot of services
will be global services.
And then on top of that or beside that
you will have a local flavor
but what I see, and for example
it's the blockchain projects,
the registration of diplomas,
now it's done by countries by themselves.
I expect this will be a global surface.
We bring people from all these coalitions
and all these communities
together to work on these
challenges, which are
mainly global challenges.
And I think at this moment,
the first step to bring
these experts together,
they need each other,
for example, the blockchain experts
they need more and more data,
and so they need the experts
from the big data working
group, but also the data experts
from the artificial
intelligence working group.
So the next step is to
build brother collaborations
worldwide.
And I hope the Netherlands
can be the gateway
to Europe for many services.
- The future of government
services should be something
that happens without the
customer asking for it.
We know what the customers want,
why not deliver it to them?
Why not go to the customer,
instead of having a customer
come to us, we want to relate it more
to the digital experience
that customers today have
with online shopping, where
they get recommendations
on what to buy based on their
previous searches on the time
of the year, we want to be
something similar to that
and maybe even more proactive.
We are aware that the
way education is going to
be delivered is going to change.
We are aware that healthcare
is going to change,
all of these services need
to be integrated in a way
and in a manner that makes it seamless
to the customer is to the
investor of the future.
- We have taken most of
our services online already
but now it's the matter of
actually measuring the quality
of the services.
How do they function?
What could be improved?
What's the journey behind,
you can do most of the stuff online,
but we still have lots
of relic in the process.
In Estonia when we opened up
our services to non citizens
using the e-Residency, that
means that we might have
some Estonian documents
from time to time pop up
to the foreigners in our systems.
That's something that needs to be worked.
We work in towards the
perception of having this
seamless background services.
Once you are born, we
already know your name.
We know your birthdate.
We know quite a lot of things about you.
Same for medicine, for example.
We're looking at some
of the ways where we can
predict what illnesses you
might have or genetic about you
and the like.
- We've been very pragmatic
in a sense to say, look
let's figure out how to solve
this organizational illegally
have proper safeguards in
place technology as well.
So this sort of approach
to fixing problems
and sort of solving them.
And it's a very engineer
way, even through design
is one part of it.
And the other part we have
benefited from the fact
that obviously we are small
country in that sense.
And the size doesn't matter
really for the point of view
how many people that live,
but just the, I would say
that as a small country, we
have very lean governance
in terms of how decisions are made.
And I think if oftentimes,
if countries asking me, okay
so what makes us don't a bit more nimble,
because decision-making is
faster and not too many levels
of government to consult and so forth.
So that's what has allowed
us to go quite a bit way.
And I've seen in bigger countries too,
if some decision-making
gets streamlined, of course
in democratic context, then
you're able to make leaps.
Because tech moves fast, you
have to be able to move faster
along as well.
- What were really change the world,
is when enlightened
progressive governments
are able to easily connect with
enlightened active citizens,
because that's a potent force.
You bring those two things
together and we can do
some really amazing things.
This sort of tension that
exists between communities
and governments, because
communities have great expectation
that governments try hard,
but they struggle to meet
those expectations.
In a digital world you can
deliver more consistently
and getting access to information and data
when they need it,
creating more of a seamless
channel between when the data
is created by government
or collected by government
and the desire to be access that,
simply because we wanna know
what government is collecting
on us, but also to be able
to make better decisions
and to develop solutions.
There will be a much
greater degree of automation
in the future.
And this will be both
in the digital world,
so the use of artificial intelligence,
but also through robotics.
And so we will have questions about,
what does that mean to
the human experience?
What does that mean to jobs?
What does that mean to the
personal connection we have
between an individual and a provider?
So we'll see all the positives
of automation and artificial intelligence.
We also gotta be conscious
of what that means
ultimately to us as humans.
We have to decide what
we want to do about that.
There'll be more change
in the next 10 to 20 years
than in the last 100 years,
when it comes to government experience
it's gonna be a remarkable time.
- All the different
methodologies available today
including the GX program are amazing.
They can change how citizens are served.
They can change how citizens
you and I access services
at a government level in
the country of our choice.
I really believe governments
need to look at GX
as a program that can
bring a new wave of energy,
that can bring efficiency
and accountability
in their government.
- The United Nations predicts
that global population
will reach 9.8 billion people by 2050.
This means more expectations
from governments
to serve citizens better and
create better experiences.
This means a more complex
world with new stakeholders,
new challenges, and
new speeds of response.
In 2020 humanity battle, a new
challenge, COVID 19 pandemic
many government struggled
to cope with the pandemic
and yet many succeeded beyond
expectations in managing,
controlling and eliminating
the threat of the pandemic.
One thing all responsive
and successful governments
did was their ability to respond fast,
to engage with citizens
and to focus on success
while looking to the future.
It is these governments,
thinkers, leaders and trailblazers
that are in the process of
creating a better world.
- If you believe that
there is a social contract
between the governed and the government,
then the things that
governments need to keep in mind
when they provide services is,
what people really want to
get from that relationship.
- Sometimes the solution that will work
in one place won't work in another.
So being very curious about
the histories and cultures
in which you're working
in order to match up
the services with the particular residents
or citizens that they're serving,
I think is a real leadership skill.
- Making it an outside in
approach to services delivery
as opposed to inside the government out,
is a change of a paradigm of
how government traditionally
develops and delivers
policy, and then thinks
about service delivery.
- Challenges that governments
face are no longer technical
in nature, those we
figured out how to solve.
The problems that are facing
governments today are more
around wicked problems,
such as how do we solve homelessness?
How do we improve food delivery to people?
How do we improve
people's quality of life?
- We started with public policy
focusing a lot on markets
and market failure and how
government had to solve problems
with market failure.
I think that's still an important
thing, but I think we have
to go beyond that now and
understand that equity
and justice are really
important factors that we have
to take into account and
figure out how we can devise
public policies that make sure
that we're being equitable
and we're being fair and just.
- There are places that are excelling
in doing digital services,
but I have yet to see
a government that then harvest
the data on the backend
for customer insight,
for predictive analytics,
geospatial analysis and
really optimizing performance.
- Just because you have a
large, large dataset does not
necessarily mean it can
help you in any way,
if you can't unlock value or
information from that raw data.
And so the way I think about
how government can play a role
is to really focus on
information that's valuable
for constituents, for
policy makers, for citizens,
for residents, or for
visitors, use that information
to all be on the same page
for what success looks like
and how to assess whether
or not you've hit criteria
that you've set and then ultimately learn
and iterate from there.
- I think customers have expectations
that are drastically different
than what governments
offered today and services.
And we should bridge the gap.
- I worry that in a downturn,
we're gonna have to be even
more efficient in the way we serve.
And with the expansion of digital
services, we need to think
about how we do old fashioned
services in a new way.
- One thing that we do within
a city can impact traffic,
which can impact housing,
which can impact the migration of people.
We have to consider everything
within systems and within
the greater mechanisms
of this and not just
on individual decisions
- Make sure you have
the right business cases
and the right governance in
place that you can't innovate
if it takes a year to
approve a business case
to do a new service.
- The one thing that government
needs to focus on primarily,
is really trying to understand
community it's at the very
micro level of a city.
And using technology is one
way to be able to do that
but also being able to embed themselves
within communities deeply to understand
the greatest challenges
that people face every scene
and then being able to use that data
in a way that can actually affect change.
- This next generation
cares more about issues
like the planet, issues
about housing equality
than previous generations.
But I think we have to make
government attractive to them.